esta mañana aquí en este monumento de la
ciudad declamatoria hemos visto llegar
muy lentamente personas trayendo flores
vienen mujeres ya mayores o vienen
incluso hijas con sus padres que
recuerdan a sus abuelos a recordar
aquellas personas que lucharon durante
la segunda guerra mundial algunos de
ellos fallecieron durante la guerra
otros habían sobrevivido pero obviamente
ya han muerto después de tantos años y
estas imágenes se repiten en otras
ciudades de ucrania ese fue el segundo
país que conformaba la unión soviética
que más muertos puso durante la segunda
guerra mundial e incluso ciudades como
kiev o 10a o de assa fueron nombradas
ciudades eróticas por su defensa y su
participación en esta guerra sin embargo
obviamente por la situación de la guerra
y lo que ha sucedido en el este del país
hace que esta fecha en este año sea
diferente muchos de ellos nos dicen que
aquí no ha venido nadie comparado con
otros años que estaría lleno de niños y
también nos dicen que para ellos muchas
de las personas que han estado aquí que
no quieren salir en cámaras nos dicen
que esta guerra no se entiende que si
nos cuenta la verdad nosotros no vamos
y también dicen que el gobierno de
ucrania ha querido imponer en los
últimos años que estas fechas se celebre
el 8 de mayo como pasa en el resto de
europa pero están aquí ellos hoy los que
han venido a celebrarlo el 9 de mayo
como se celebra en moscú